come on let's practice the dance for my
song that I hate
[Music]
wait that's pretty accurate you'll have
to watch more of the shows yeah Lily
Rose death reacts to SNL's Chloe
fireman's roast of her character Jocelyn
a troubled pop star in HBO's The Idol I
just don't want to like make a fool of
myself
I want people to like make fun of me
they're not
trust me
it's like like really the
I want to like humiliate myself but then
kind of also do
yeah Chloe brought the last Thursday
when she shared a parody of standout
moments from the premiere episode on
Instagram a clip that left Lily Rose
quote loling with a number of emojis and
also shouting out Chloe's makeup does my
songs suck like music should sound like
a [__] or a [__] Chloe captioned the
Instagram post my audition for the idol
must have got lost in the mail Lily Rose
death is a goddess of talent thank you
thank you very much
let's get into the accuracy here
wardrobe and all first up is this scene
Chloe recreates where Jocelyn rehearses
for a music video and in the details the
tiny black bra which Chloe wears
backwards Chrissy Teigen who popped up
in the comments had a good laugh I'm
obsessed with it
[Music]
come on let's practice the dose for my
song that I hear
SNL Sarah Sherman also chimed in in the
comments with a big laugh with singer
Michelle Branch writing that she's quote
dying from laughter shits Creek's Emily
Hampshire says this is genius that
to me was like wow then there's more the
SNL star rocks red lingerie acting out
this moment where Jocelyn's love
interest played by the weekend seduces
her
oh you can say
insane now seeing like you can
do you believe
[Music]
and in the episode Jocelyn's a big
cigarette smoker Yep looks like Chloe
understood the assignment music should
sound like it's Polly or like pie or
like
music doesn't have a gender you know
judging by Lily Rose's comment seems the
star didn't take the parody to heart and
just might be a fan ahead of the show's
release she opened up to ET about where
she received inspiration for Jocelyn
there's so many incredible pop stars of
of today that I that I you know have
nothing but admiration and respect for
and of course that you can't help but
think of when you're thinking about
um a character like Jocelyn but um I
definitely we're definitely not telling
anybody else's story or or trying to
um base her on any any real person and
we actually Drew from a lot of other
influences that are not pop stars like
you know we thought a lot about uh
Sharon Stone in Basic Instinct and uh
you know the kind of Gene tierneys and
Lauren McCall's of the world and Jean
mahu and like all of these other women
that were very
um uh that were very inspiring to me for
for the role
foreign